and i realized these guys are not just
calling trump hitler
they're calling they're calling all the
trump supporters nazis that's half of
the country
christian amanpour who drew clavin calls
christian christian
i'm a poor journalist said on cnn she
made this explicit comparison
compared trump supporters to nazis
and evoked krystal knocked this week
82 years ago kristallnacht happened it
was the nazis warning shot across the
bow of our human civilization
that led to genocide against a whole
identity
and in that tower of burning books it
led to an attack on fact
knowledge history and truth after four
years of a modern day assault on those
same values by donald trump
the biden harris team pledges a return
to norms
including the truth and every day joe
biden makes presidential announcements
about good governance
and the health and security of the
american people while the great brooding
figure of his defeated opponent
rages conducting purges of deceived
enemies
and preventing a transition so
everything in there obviously is false
what's so funny is as christian amanpour
is
talking about how the conservatives are
burning books target was taking my
friend abigail schreier's book off the
shelves
because she suggested maybe we shouldn't
trans the kids
her book is called irreversible damage
it's a terrific book
target removed it because she said they
said it was transphobic it's not true
abigail schreiber by the way believes
that if you're an adult you should be
able to
be a man and identify as a woman and go
through the medical
cosmetic procedures to look more like a
woman and identify as a woman she's
totally on board with that she just
thinks she shouldn't trans the kids
take them off the shelves we made a big
deal about it on on friday
and finally target actually did
acquiesce because
when conservatives have courage when
they grow a spine turns out we can
actually do things
but that's that's what's happening there
how about you're worried about crystal
notch you're worried about the
broken gla you might have broken glass
you're worried about all these things i
notice
that there are a lot of boards in a lot
of shop windows in major cities in
america
do you know why those are up because
they felt the shop owners felt
that if trump won leftists would smash
up their windows
christian amanpour exactly reverses it
says it's going to be conservatives who
do that conservatives haven't done that
like ever i don't think they've done it
once i hope you enjoyed that short
segment from the michael knowles show be
sure to check out the full episode
linked in the description
or download the podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
[Music]